فِي مَنْزِلِ أُنْثَى السِّنْجَابْ دَقَّ دَقَّ البَابْ
دق دق دق ، مَنْ بِالْبَابْ؟
عَيْشِي فِي المَزْرَعَةِ يَطِيبْ  ***  يَعْرِفُنِي بَعِيدٌ وَقَرِيبْ
أُعْطِيكُمْ جُبْنًا وَحَلِيبْ
أَهْلًا أَهْلًا يَا بَقَرَةْ *** أَهْلًا يَا أَغْلَى الأصْحَابْ
هيا نَسْمَعْ صَوْتَ خُوَارِكْ *** كَيْ نَفْتَحَ فِي الحَالِ البَابْ
مووو مووو
فِي مَنْزِلِ أُنْثَى السِّنْجَابْ دَقَّ دَقَّ البَابْ
دق دق دق ، مَنْ بِالْبَابْ؟
أَبْيَضُ يَكْسُو جِسْمِي صُوفْ  ***  وَبِأَكْلِ العُشْبِ مَعْرُوفْ
هَذَا أَنَا أَحَدُ الضُّيُوفْ
أَهْلًا بِكَ أَهْلًا يَا خَرُوفْ ***  أَهْلًا يَا أَغْلَى الْأَصْحَابْ
هيا أسْمَعْ مَأْمَأَتَكْ ***  كَيْ نَفْتَحَ فْي الحَالِ البَابْ
باااء باااء
فِي مَنْزِلِ أُنْثَى السِّنْجَابْ دَقَّ دَقَّ البَابْ
دق دق دق ، مَنْ بِالْبَابْ؟
حَسْنَاءٌ وَلَدَيَّ قُرُونْ ***  وَلَدِي الجَدْيُ أَلَا تَدْرُونْ
هَلْ عَرَفْتُمْ مَنْ أَكُونْ
أَهْلًا يَا مِعْزَةُ أَهْلًا ***  أَهْلًا يَا أَغْلَى الأصْحَابْ
هيا نَسْمَعْ صَوْتَ ثُغَائِكْ ***  كَيْ نَفْتَحَ فْي الحَالِ البَابْ
ماااء ماااء
فِي مَنْزِلِ أُنْثَى السِّنْجَابْ دَقَّ دَقَّ البَابْ
دق دق دق ، مَنْ بِالْبَابْ؟
يَكْسُونِي رِيشٌ وَفِيرْ ***  لِي جَنَاحَانِ وَلَا أَطِيرْ
وَالصُّوصُ وَلَدِي الصَّغِيرْ
أَهْلًا يَا دَجَاجَةُ أَهْلًا ***  أَهْلًا يَا أَغْلَى الأصْحَابْ
هيا نَسْمَعْ صَوْتَ نَقِيقِكْ ***  كَيْ نَفْتَحَ فْي الحَالِ البَابْ
كاااك كاااك
فِي مَنْزِلِ أُنْثَى السِّنْجَابْ دَقَّ دَقَّ البَابْ
دق دق دق ، مَنْ بِالْبَابْ؟
جِسْمِي يَهْتَزُّ وَيَمِيلْ ***  رِيشٌ يَكْسُو جِسْمِي جَمِيلْ
مِنْقَارِي عَرِيضٌ وَطَوِيلْ
أَهْلًا أَهْلًا يَا بَطَّةْ  *** أَهْلًا يَا أَغْلَى الأصْحَابْ
هَيَّا نَسْمَعْ بَطْبَطَتَكْ ***  كَيْ نَفْتَحَ فْي الحَالِ البَابْ
واااك واااك
فِي مَنْزِلِ أُنْثَى السِّنْجَابْ دَقَّ دَقَّ البَابْ
دق دق دق ، مَنْ بِالْبَابْ؟
شَعْرِي جَمِيلٌ ذَيْلِي  طَوِيلْ  *** وَلِصَيْدِ الفِئْرَانِ أَمِيلْ
أَخْرُجُ أَتَجَوَّلُ بِاللَّيْل
أَهْلًا يَا قِطَّة أهلا *** أَهْلًا يَا أَغْلَى الأصْحَابْ
هيا نَسْمَعْ صَوْتَ مُوَائِكْ *** كَيْ نَفْتَحَ فْي الحَالِ البَابْ
مياوو مياوو
فِي مَنْزِلِ أُنْثَى السِّنْجَابْ دَقَّ دَقَّ البَابْ
دق دق دق ، مَنْ بِالْبَابْ؟
أُعْرَفُ بِصَدِيقِ الإِنْسَانْ *** أَيْضًا أَنَا أَوْفَى حَيَوَانْ
اِفْتَحُوا قَدْ جِئْتُ الآنْ
أَهْلًا يَا كَلْبُ وَسَهْلًا *** أَهْلًا يَا أَغْلَى الأصْحَابْ
هيا نَسْمَعْ صَوْتَ نُبَاحِكْ *** كَيْ نَفْتَحَ فْي الحَالِ البَابْ
هوو هوو
فِي مَنْزِلِ أُنْثَى السِّنْجَابْ دَقَّ دَقَّ البَابْ